il revient en bourgogne avec sa
casquette de candidat à la primaire
arnaud montebourg était à dijon
aujourd'hui arrivés à midi il s'est
d'abord rendu dans le centre ville il a
ensuite visité une entreprise de
réinsertion allons discuter lisais dans
la sous traitance industrielle puis un
fab lab la fabrique où il a notamment
rencontré les jeunes d'unis cité avant
de tenir ce soir un meeting au palais
des congrès arnaud montebourg est
l'invité de ce journal bonsoir à vous
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous merci
votre invitation
alors on l'a appris aujourd'hui il ya
encore un nouveau candidat dans cette
primaire vincent peillon l'un de vos
anciens amis
qu'est ce qui vous différencie des
autres aujourd'hui je défends un
programme de redécollage économique qui
met fin à l'austérité d'inspiration
bruxelloise européenne ça a été un des
points de rupture au gouvernement
lorsque j'étais au ministère de
l'économie était impossible d'obtenir de
françois hollande de manuel valls
la redéfinition la réorientation de
notre politique économique
la conséquence est un million de
chômeurs en catégorie a b c
cinq cent cinquante six mille chômeurs
en catégorie à la même contre
performance que dans le quinquennat
sarkozy
et donc il y a une responsabilité à ne
pas continuer cette politique sur ce
point de rupture passe en payant c'est
un bon candidat
côté juniors ce qu'il propose je ne
commente vraiment pas toutes les
candidatures ça devient difficile
est ce que c'est un candidat pour
affaiblir comme l'a dit manuel valls
écoutez ce que je sais c'est que la
primaire est un système de rassemblement
où la discussion et constructive c'est à
dire où nous sommes sur les projets bien
sûr les arrête aussi qu'on a pu avoir
les uns les autres mais surtout c'est le
moyen de commencer le premier
rassemblement et une fois que le
vainqueur désigné si je le suis avec le
soutien du peuple de gauche
mon travail sera de nous réunifiée avec
d'autres candidats c'est le cas par
exemple de jean luc mélenchon de yannick
jadot
je défends l'idée que nous devons mettre
à crier d'où devons construire un
programme commun j'ignore si emmanuel
macron et de gauche il diluerait jouer
ni droite ni gauche il a même déclaré je
crois que dans le programme françois
fillon il y avait de bonnes choses je ne
les ai pas trouvé personnellement
donc c'est un processus de rassemblement
et si nous n'y parvenons pas nous avons
une responsabilité historique
les électeurs le peuple de gauche n'aura
le choix qu'entre monsieur fillon et
madame le pen ce qui est un véritable
problème
alors justement la gauche éparpillée
divisés selon un dernier sondage
elle ne serait pas au deuxième tour de
la présidentielle on prenait tout ce
rassemblement mais vous partez tous de
l'autre côté
non la primaire est un outil de
rassemblement collectif
c'est un premier rassemblement et
ensuite il faudra discuter avec ceux qui
ne sont pas dans la primaire
ils ne veulent pas y venir je crois que
c'est un tort mais appartient au moment
où ils refusent cette espèce de loyauté
collective
eh bien il faudra tendre la main aller
les chercher et travailler enfin alors
un autre et vous il n'y a pas trop de
candidats vous n'êtes pas en train de
faire du tort à la gauche en étant aussi
nombreux
écoutez je ne suis responsable que de ma
propre candidature j'étais déjà présent
il ya cinq ans je note que j'ai quitté
le gouvernement sur des points de
rupture de fond avec l'austérité
européenne le refus finalement du made
in france
j'ai donc décidé de porter le contenu de
ce que je crois depuis longtemps dans
cette dans cette primaire alors il ya un
autre candidat qui est en train de
s'exprimer au moment même où on parle en
franche comté à audincourt c'est manuel
valls c'est un candidat sérieux qui se
met sur votre route j'ai trouvé que sa
déclaration de candidature était un
discours d'opposant à sa propre
politique
finalement car ils disaient qu'ils
voulaient la démocratie mais la
gouverner avec le 49-3 pour ma part je
propose l'établissement d'une république
nouvelle je défends depuis 15 ans la
sixième république et j'ai noté qu' il
voulait préserver le modèle social mais
il a fait la loi travail
je suis favorable à l'abrogation de la
loi elle conneries nous ne pouvons pas
affaiblir les salariés dans une période
difficile pour eux dans cette période de
crise
donc nous avons des divergences c'est au
peuple de gauche de venir en masse à la
primaire nous donner la force d'abord
d'arbitré nos choix et ensuite pour ma
part d'avoir une stratégie de
réconciliation des gauches
je notais là encore que l'ancien premier
ministre
était le théoricien des gauches
irréconciliables comment voulez vous que
nous réussissions si nous ne sommes pas
capables de nous réconcilier
alors il reste sept semaines de campagne
comment vous vous comptez convaincre les
français eh bien d'abord je fais une
campagne de terrain je me rends dans les
chaînes locales auprès de la presse
quotidienne de proximité je rencontre
les français et je n'épargne aucune
région et cela fait partie je crois
d'aller à la rencontre des français de
leur vie quotidienne pour faire des
propositions tout à fait importantes sur
la santé les déserts médicaux urbains ou
ruraux
je propose de créer par exemple des
dispensaires de la sécurité sociale où
nous allons salariés des médecins
d'ailleurs beaucoup de médecins libéraux
sont épuisés ils veulent aussi être
salarié dans de bonnes conditions
il y à des candidatures nous pourrons
ainsi régler enfin ce problème je
propose que pour dans la santé puisque
c'est un sujet central dans cette
campagne avec les propositions très dur
de privatisation de la sécurité sociale
de monsieur fillon
je propose que pour les sans mutuelle la
sécurité sociale propose une mutuelle à
prix modéré pour permettre à ceux qui ne
sont pas la cmu ne peuvent pas s'offrir
une mutuelle d'y accéder je propose sur
la l'éducation nationale qu' on coupe
les classes en petits groupes et que
nous donnions les moyens dans les
endroits où il ya trop d'échec scolaire
qui laisse les enfants sur le carreau on
ne peut pas dans notre pays à voir les
savoirs fondamentaux qui ne sont pas
maîtrisés et qui donne le sentiment de
s'effondrer merci arnaud montebourg
notre âme et permet d'en présenter des
propositions
le merci beaucoup